♪ ♪
>> Kennedy: CNN ONCE AGAIN
TAKING HEAT FOR MOCKING TRUMP
SUPPORTERS.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> HE KNOWS DEEP IN HIS HEART
THAT DONALD TRUMP COULDN’T FIND
UKRAINE ON THE MAP IF YOU HAD
THE U AND A PICTURE OF A CRANE
NEXT TO IT.
HE KNOWS THIS IS AN
ADMINISTRATION DEFINED BY
IGNORANCE OF THE WORLD SO THAT
IS PARTLY HIM PLAYING TO THEIR
BASE AND THEIR AUDIENCE, THE
CREDULOUS BOOMER RUBES THAT
BACKS DONALD TRUMP.
THAT WANTS TO THINK DONALD TRUMP
IS THE SMART ONE, AND Y’ALL
ELITISTS ARE DUMB WITH YOUR
GEOGRAPHY AND YOUR MAPS AND YOUR
SPELLING, YOUR MATH AND YOUR
READING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THAT WAS GOOD, SORRY.
THAT WAS A GOOD ONE, I NEEDED
THAT.
>> Kennedy: LOOK AT YOUR BIAS.
THE LIBERAL NETWORK GETTING
INTENSE BACKLASH AND THE
PRESIDENT IS FIGHTING BACK,
SAYING "DON LEMON, THE DUMBEST
MAN ON TELEVISION WITH TERRIBLE
RATINGS."
IVANKA TRUMP CALLING THE CLIP
DISGUSTING.
GREG, IS THIS ONE OF THOSE
MOMENTS WHERE THE MEDIA LEFT
SHOW THEIR BIAS AGAINST A LARGE
CHUNK OF THE COUNTRY?
>> Greg: I DID COME UP WITH A
DRINK THAT IS CALLED THE LEMON
RICKY.
IT IS HALF POMPOUS.
I’M ALL FOR RIDICULE, YOU
RIDICULE THE GUY, THOUGH, BUT
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS CNN AS
THEY RIDICULE EVERYBODY.
THIS HAS ALWAYS BEEN KIND OF
THERE THING.
THEY REALLY DO LOOK DOWN THEIR
NOSES AT AT LEAST HALF OF
AMERICA, AND WONDER WHY THEIR
RATINGS ARE IN THE TANK.
IF THAT IS A PURE CAMPAIGN AD, I
WILL SAY THIS, RICK WILSON,
THERE’S DEFINITELY SOMETHING
WRONG WITH HIM.
THE JOKE WASN’T THAT BAD.
IT WAS LEMONS OVERDOING IT,
HYPERDRAMATIC, OH, MY GOD, THIS
IS THE BEST THING EVER LIKE HE
WAS HAVING AN ORGASM.
>> Kennedy: LIKE JIMMY FALLON
ON "SNL."
>> Greg: DON’T COMPARE THE
TWO.
CNN NEEDS HELP, THEY ARE IN
TROUBLE.
THE MEDIA CREW WAS WATCHING FOX
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WE ARE DOING
RIGHT.
>> Kennedy: MAY BE RESPECTING
PEOPLE’S VOTES AND PEOPLE’S
POINTS OF VIEW, EVEN WHEN THEY
DON’T SQUARE WITH YOUR OWN, AND
I THINK THAT IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST PROBLEMS, WHAT YOU SEE
HERE.
>> Dana: WELL, MANY PEOPLE ARE
THE FIRST TO TRY TO POINT OUT,
RICK WILSON AND OTHERS, WHEN THE
PRESIDENT SAYS SOMETHING
IMPOLITE OR HARSH ABOUT ANOTHER
PERSON, AND I DON’T LIKE IT
EITHER, I’VE SAID IT FROM THE
BEGINNING.
ALTHOUGH THE NICKNAME I REALLY
LIKED WAS A LITTLE ROCKET MAN,
THE ONES THAT ARE PERSONAL IN
NATURE I DON’T LIKE.
AND AS SOON AS HILLARY CLINTON
SAID DEPLORABLE, I KNEW THAT WAS
IT.
HERE WE GO.
I ALSO UNDERSTAND, USING A
SOUTHERN ACCENT TO MIMIC
SOMEBODY WHO IS APPARENTLY DUMB
AND DOESN’T READ IS REALLY
OFFENSIVE.
PEOPLE COME FROM DIFFERENT
REGIONS OF THE COUNTRY, ACCENTS
FROM PEOPLE ALL OVER THE WORLD,
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH YOUR
INTELLIGENCE.
IT HAS TO DO WITH WHERE YOU ARE
RAISED.
THAT IS OFFENSIVE.
>> Greg: HOW MANY SURGEONS
HAVE SOUTHERN ACCENTS?
I’M PRETTY SURE A MILLION.
>> Jesse: THAT IS WHY I DON’T
MAKE SWEEPING GENERALIZATIONS
ABOUT LARGE GROUPS OF PEOPLE,
GREG.
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dana: RELAY, STARTING NOW?
>> Jesse: THAT’S RIGHT.
I’M NOT THAT OFFENDED BY IT AND
I’M NOT OFFENDED ON BEHALF OF
SOMEONE BY THAT BUT I’M USUALLY
THE ONE THAT OFFENDS OTHER
PEOPLE, SO STAY OUT OF MY LANE.
[LAUGHTER]
NOW, I HAVE A UNIQUE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE SITUATION.
THE TWO GUYS ON THE RIGHT AND
LEFT, THEY ARE NOT GOING TO PAY
A PRICE.
THERE’S NO PARENT COMPANY THERE.
DON LEMON IS THE GUY IN TROUBLE
BECAUSE HE IS SUPPOSED TO BE THE
STRAIGHT NEWS GUY AND CNN IS
ALREADY IN TROUBLE WITH BAD
RATINGS, AND HE’S GOT PROBLEMS
ON THE SIDE, SO I’M SURE, HE
CALLS HIM INTO THE OFFICE AND
SAYS, GUYS, YOU ARE A PRIME TIME
PERSON, AND YOU’RE LOSING IT
BECAUSE SOMEONE IS MAKING FUN OF
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS FOR BEING
DUMB SOUTHERNERS.
>> Dana: YOU THINK THAT IS THE
CONVERSATION WITH MARK I THINK
HE IS GOING, DON, THAT WAS
BRILLIANT!
YOUR COMEDIC INSTINCTS WERE SPOT
ON!
>> Jesse: IF THAT IS WHAT IS
HAPPENING AT CNN THAN THEY
DESERVE THE RIDICULE.
IT WILL TURN AROUND AND GIVE A
TALKING POINT TO EVERY
REPUBLICAN, TO DONALD TRUMP TO
HAMMER THE LEFT, TO HAMMER THE
MEDIA IN AN ELECTION YEAR WHERE
DEMOCRATS HAVE TO REGAIN THEIR
FOOTING WITH WHITE WORKING-CLASS
AMERICANS, NONCOLLEGE EDUCATED
PEOPLE IN IOWA, FLORIDA, AND THE
RUST BELT, SO NOT GREAT TIMING.
>> Kennedy: THERE ARE PLENTY
OF PEOPLE IN THE SOUTH WHO HAVE
ADVANCED DEGREES WHO LOOK AT
PEOPLE LIKE BERNIE SANDERS AND
SAY, HE DOES NOT REPRESENT MY
INTERESTS, I LIKE MY MONEY, I
WANT TO TAKE CARE OF MY
CHILDREN, I WILL NOT VOTE FOR
HIM SO I WILL VOTE FOR
DONALD TRUMP YOU’RE NOT
EVERYBODY HAS A SOUTHERN ACCENT.
A DEPLORABLE RUBE!
>> Juan: I AGREE, NO ARGUMENT
THERE.
I’M SURPRISED, THEY DIDN’T TAKE
ANY GREAT OFFENSE AT THIS, IF
YOU WANT TO HAVE THIS KIND OF
RIDICULE, I SUPPOSE IS THE WORD
YOU USED.
>> Greg: RIDICULE IS GREAT
WHEN IT IS DIRECTED AT A PERSON
BUT NOT A GROUP OF PEOPLE.
THEY DIRECTED IT AT A GROUP OF
PEOPLE.
>> Juan: MSNBC IS A LIBERAL
NETWORK, CNN IS LIBERAL.
DON LEMON, I DON’T THINK HE IS A
STRAIGHT NEWS GUY.
I THINK HE IS AN OPINION HOST.
>> Jesse: HE IS ON CAMERA
SAYING HE IS A STRAIGHT NEWS
GUY.
>> Juan: I DISAGREE BECAUSE HE
DOES OPINION, MONOLOGUE.
>> Jesse: I AGREE, HE’S VERY
OPINIONATED.
HE HAS THIS CHARADE AS A
STRAIGHT NEWS GUY.
>> Kennedy: I DON’T MIND THAT.
>> Jesse: I’M JEALOUS OF THAT.
WHY DON’T WE TAKE SHOTS ON
FOX NEWS ON NEW YEAR’S?
THEY CAN GET AWAY WITH ANYTHING.
>> Juan: RICK WILSON IS A
REPUBLICAN FOR HIS WHOLE CAREER,
THAT IS HOW HE BECAME RICK
WILSON.
>> Greg: NO, HE FOUND HIS
IDENTITY BEING SOMETHING ELSE.
HE’S GOT A DISORDER.